hey guys my name is Jess McDonald today
it's the 6th of April and you're
watching games with you if you bought
the Tomb Raider reboot I'm sorry to tell
you that you're not at all special since
everybody did well 8.5 million people at
least the 2013 Tomb Raider game
developed by Crystal Dynamics sold an
extra 1.5 million copies in just the
last 2 months
the overall figure makes this and tree
the best-selling Tomb Raider game in the
franchise interestingly the game's first
month sales tally of 3.6 million units
didn't impress publisher Square Enix at
the time they were hoping for a more
impressive target the 8.5 million figure
does include sales of the definitive
edition which launched this January on
Xbox one and ps4 pillars of eternity
developer obsidian have removed a
limerick from their recently released
RPG after some found it to be offensive
the Limerick which was believed to be
trans misogynistic was written by one of
the game's Kickstarter backers obsidian
CEO Fergus Burkhart wrote on the game's
forum it's come to our attention that a
piece of backer created content has made
it into pillars of eternity that was not
vetted once it was brought to our
attention it followed the same vetting
process as all of our other content the
backer in question has since provided a
new Limerick to obsidian which you can
uncover in the game as part of its
latest 1.03 patch it's no secret that
Nintendo's YouTube revenue policy is
controversial but now popular YouTube
personality angry Joe is broken up
against it after finding himself on the
receiving end of that policy angry Joe
Vargas posted a Mario Party 10 video
recently which has now received a
copyright complaint from Nintendo the
company recently launched their YouTube
creators program
which means Nintendo will take a share
of the profits from all videos that
utilize that content this is a pretty
big claim of somebody like Angry Joe who
has almost 2 million subscribers true to
his alias angry Joe in
happy about Nintendo's quote needs to
monetize calling Nintendo effin greedy
and anti youtuber he tweeted a picture
of Nintendo's copyright claim with the
caption I hope Nintendo enjoyed the free
ad revenue and coverage I generated for
them it will be my last Nintendo video
angry Joe lamented that he spent around
$900 on his way cutaneous set up and has
since deleted his Mario Party video let
me know down in the comments if you
think this means gente copyright program
has gone too far or if you think it's
fair you can add to GameSpot we've got
stories on Dragon's Dogma online and the
new system update for the Xbox one
that is it for me today as always let me
know what you cared about and I'll catch
you same time tomorrow
[Music]